>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
JUST A WEEK TO GO FROM TONIGHT
UNTIL THE MIDTERMS AND ELECTION
DAY IS FINALLY BECOMING A
REFERENDUM ON SOMETHING THAT
REALLY MATTERS, IMMIGRATION.
WHO GETS TO LIVE HERE?
WHAT DOES CITIZENSHIP MEAN?
WHAT KIND OF COUNTRY DO WE WANT?
THESE ARE NOT SMALL INCIDENTAL
QUESTIONS AND WHAT YOU'RE
WATCHING IS NOT AN ARGUMENT
ABOUT RUSSIAN FACEBOOK ADS OR
STORMY DANIELS OR HER CREEPY
LAWYER, SOME OTHER DIVERSION
DESIGNED TO PREVENT YOU FROM
THINKING CLEARLY.
THESE ARE CORE DEBATES.
THESE ARE THE ARGUMENTS THAT
EVERY FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACY MUST
HAVE AND YET HOURS RARELY DOES.
CONSIDER THE QUESTION OF
BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP.
UNDER CURRENT INTERPRETATIONS OF
AMERICAN LAW, ANYONE BORN ON OUR
SOIL AUTOMATICALLY BECOMES A
U.S. CITIZEN.
CONTEXT IS IRRELEVANT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOUR
PARENTS WERE TOURISTS OR ILLEGAL
ALIENS OR FOREIGN SABOTEURS, IF
THEIR PLANE WAS FORCED DOWN TO
REFUEL AND YOU EMERGED.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
IF YOU WERE BORN ON OUR PROPERTY
YOU ARE A CITIZEN.
IN A RECENT INTERVIEW WITH AXIOS
PRESIDENT TRUMP SUGGESTED THIS
IS NOT A GREAT DEAL FOR AMERICA.
HE PLEDGED TO CHANGE IT WITH AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
IT SEEMS LIKELY THAT WOULD
ABOLISH BIRTH TOURISM, THAT'S
WHERE PEOPLE TRAVEL TO THE UNIT
STATE SOLELY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
HAVING KIDS AND WINNING
CITIZENSHIP AS LONG AS THE MANY
BENEFITS THAT FOLLOW FROM THAT.
NOBODY ELSE IN WASHINGTON IS
WAITING FOR DETAILS.
IF THEY HATE ALREADY.
THE VERY SAME PEOPLE WHO SPENT
DECADES TRYING TO GOT THE GOT
THE BILL OF RIGHTS ARE NOW
LECTURING THE REST OF US THAT
THE IDEA IS, BRACE HERSELF,
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
PAUL RYAN FOR EXAMPLE, THE
OUTGOING SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
HE ANNOUNCED HIS OPPOSITION TO
THIS IMMEDIATELY.
THE VERY IDEA, HE SAID, IS
RIDICULOUS, LISTEN.
>> YOU OBVIOUSLY CANNOT DO THAT.
YOU CANNOT END BIRTHRIGHT
CITIZENSHIP WITH AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER.
>> Tucker: OBVIOUSLY,
OBVIOUSLY.
NOT THE PHRASING.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE SAY WHEN THEY
DON'T FEEL LIKE MAKING A
RATIONAL CASE FOR THEIR
POSITIONS, USUALLY BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T.
IS IT REALLY "OBVIOUS" THAT THE
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES US TO GIVE
CITIZENSHIP TO THE CHILDREN OF
ILLEGAL ALIENS?
PAUL RYAN HAS NO IDEA, HE JUST
DOESN'T WANT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT IT.
HE WANTS YOU TO BE QUIET.
IN FACT, AS A LEGAL MATTER IT IS
AN OPEN QUESTION.
THE SUPREME COURT HAS NEVER
RULED ON BUT THERE IS AMPLE
REASON TO BELIEVE THE LAW DOES
NOT APPLY TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
OR BIRTH TOURISTS.
BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP ARISES
FROM THE 14TH AMENDMENT PASSED
JUST THREE YEARS AFTER THE
CIVIL WAR AND IT WAS PASSED TO
GUARANTEE CITIZENSHIP TO FREED.
THE SENATOR WHO WROTE THE
CITIZENSHIP CLAUSE IN THE 14TH
AMENDMENT, HOWARD OF MICHIGAN
EXPLAINED THE POINT OF IT ON THE
SENATE FLOOR AT THE TIME.
"THE AMENDMENT WILL NOT, OF
COURSE, INCLUDE PERSONS BORN IN
THE UNITED STATES WHO ARE
FOREIGNERS, ALIENS WHO BELONG TO
THE FAMILIES OF AMBASSADORS OR
FOREIGN MINISTERS."
AGAIN, THE AMENDMENT WAS
DESIGNED TO ENSURE THAT NEWLY
FREED WOULD BE TREATED AS THE
AMERICAN CITIZENS THEY WERE.
THE POINT WAS TO ENFRANCHISE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
THE POINT WAS NOT TO ENABLE THE
REST OF THE WORLD TO SCAM OUR
SYSTEM, TO ABUSE OUR GENEROSITY.
TRUMP'S PROPOSAL WILL GET US
CLOSER TO THE PURPOSE OF THE
14TH AMENDMENT AND FOR THAT HE
IS BEING DENOUNCED, NATURALLY,
AS A RACIST.
IF LISTEN TO SOME OF THE DUMB
PEOPLE ON TV.
>> WHAT USED TO BE FIVE YEARS
AGO, TEN YEARS AGO, DOG WHISTLES
TO APPEAL TO THE FEARS OF WHITE
VOTERS NOW ARE JUST STATED
OPENLY.
>> THE PRINCIPAL DEBATE, THE
REAL FAULT WHEN IT GETS PEOPLE
GOING IS THIS ISSUE OF OPENNESS,
HOW OPEN ARE WE TO PEOPLE, HOW
OPEN ARE WE TO TRADE IN THE
ISSUE OF NATIONAL IDENTITY
VERSUS INTERNATIONALISM,
GLOBALISM, IF YOU WILL.
SO WHAT DONALD TRUMP IS DOING IS
HE IS MINING THAT FAULT LINE.
HE IS WORKING IT WHETHER IT'S
BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP, WHETHER
IT'S SENDING TROOPS TO A BORDER
THAT'S NOT UNDER SIEGE.
WE ARE NO LONGER ARGUING SERIOUS
ISSUES ABOUT HOW TO REGULATE OUR
ECONOMY.
WE ARE NO LONGER ARGUING SERIOUS
ISSUES ABOUT HOW TO FIGHT THE
COLD WAR.
WE ARE ARGUING QUESTIONS ABOUT
NATIONAL IDENTITY AND IT'S NOT
THAT FAR TO GET FROM THAT TO
ISSUES OF RACISM.
>> Tucker: LET'S GET THIS
STRAIGHT, DEFINING CITIZENSHIP
IS NOT "A SERIOUS ISSUE"?
ONLY IN NEW YORK AND WASHINGTON
WERE SERIOUS IS WHERE TO FIND
GOOD BROADER OR HOW TO GET TO
THE HAMPTONS IN UNDER THREE
HOURS ON A FRIDAY NIGHT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE TOTAL BUFFOONS.
THERE IS NO MORE SERIOUS DEBATE
THAN THE DEBATE OVER CITIZENSHIP
AND IT'S LONG OVERDUE.
GLOBALLY BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP
IS THE RARE EXCEPTION.
IT IS NOT THE ROLE.
CANADA AND THE U.S. ARE THE ONLY
DEVELOPED COUNTRIES THAT HAVE
BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP.
IF NOT A SINGLE EUROPEAN COUNTRY
ALLOWS IT.
OUT OF THE 54 COUNTRIES IN
AFRICA, ONLY TO GO OFFER
BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP.
BY THE OTHER 52 RACIST?
HOW ABOUT HARRY REID, IS HE A
RACIST TOO?
WATCH THE FORMER DEMOCRATIC
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER EXPLAIN
HIS VIEWS ON BIRTHRIGHT
CITIZENSHIP.
>> IF MAKING IT EASY TO BE
ILLEGAL ALIEN IS ENOUGH OF A
CALL THAT AN AWARD FOR BEING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT.
NO SANE COUNTRY WOULD DO THAT,
RIGHT?
GUESS AGAIN.
IF YOU BREAK OUR LAWS BY
ENTERING THIS COUNTRY WITHOUT
PERMISSION AND GIVE BIRTH TO A
CHILD, WE REWARD THAT CHILD WITH
U.S. CITIZENSHIP AND GUARANTEE A
FULL ACCESS TO ALL PUBLIC AND
SOCIAL SERVICES THE SOCIETY
PROVIDES, AND THAT'S A LOT OF
SERVICES.
IS IT ANY WONDER THAT TWO-THIRDS
OF THE BABIES BORN AT TAXPAYER
EXPENSE, COUNTY RUN HOSPITALS IN
LOS ANGELES ARE BORN TO ILLEGAL
ALIEN MOTHERS?
>> Tucker: AS A FACTUAL MATTER
THAT'S TOUGHER THAN ANYTHING
DONALD TRUMP IS EVER SAID.
KEEP IN MIND THAT JUST FOUR
YEARS AGO THAT MAN WAS THE TOP
DEMOCRAT IN THE SENATE.
TRY SAYING THAT TODAY.
IT WOULD BE CALLED BULL CONNOR
AND SHOUTED OUT THE STAGE WITH
THE QUESTIONS HE RAISED ARE
STILL FAIR QUESTIONS.
IS BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP
HELPING THIS COUNTRY OR IS IT
HURTING THIS COUNTRY?
UNDER OUR CURRENT SYSTEM ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WHO COME TO THE U.S.
AND HAVE CHILDREN ARE ELIGIBLE
TO RECEIVE TAX CREDIT, FOOD
STAMPS AND OTHER WELFARE
BENEFITS.
THOSE ARE HUGE INCENTIVES.
NOT SURPRISINGLY, ONE IN EVERY
12 BIRTHS IN THIS COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW IS SOMEONE HERE ILLEGALLY.
THAT DOES NOT EVEN INCLUDE BIRTH
TOURISM.
EVERY YEAR TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
FOREIGN NATIONALS COME TO THIS
COUNTRY ON VISAS SOLELY TO GIVE
BIRTH TO CHILDREN.
THE CHINESE ARE OVER STRONGLY
REPRESENTED.
CHINA OFFERS HIGH END BIRTH
TOURS AND SPECIALISTS.
FOR THE DRESS 20 GRAND THESE
EXPERTS NAVIGATE CLIENTS THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF HAVING A CHILD IN
AMERICA.
IN RETURN FOR THAT 20 GRAND,
SOCIAL SECURITY, MEDICARE,
COUNTLESS OTHER PROGRAMS.
IF THEY COME BACK TO THE U.S.
FOR COLLEGE THEY GET IN-STATE
TUITION, FEDERALLY BACKED
STUDENT LOANS, FINANCIALLY.
ALL THE BENEFITS THAT ARE TO BE
GOING TO ACTUAL AMERICANS WERE
DROWNING IN COLLEGE DEBT.
THIS IS A SCAM.
THERE IS NO OTHER WORD FOR IT.
DON'T BLAME THE CHINESE OR THE
RUSSIANS OR THE SALVADORANS OR
ANYBODY ELSE USING THE SYSTEM,
WE ARE THE ONES OFFERING IT.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY TAKE IT?
THE BLAME LIES WITH US.
NO OTHER COUNTRY WOULD ALLOW
ITSELF TO BE RELENTLESSLY
EXPORTED LIKE THIS FOR DECADES
AND NO OTHER LEADERSHIP CLASS